>> Larry: WELCOME BACK.
NOW AS WE ALL KNOW ELECTION
SEASON CONTINUES TO HEAT UP
SO IT'S TIME FOR A QUICK
CHECK-IN WITH THE
UNBLACKENING, ROLL IT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
WE HAVE A NEW PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, LOUISIANA
GOVERNOR BOBBY JINDAL
ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY,
BECOMING THE 13th REPUBLICAN
TO OFFICIALLY JOIN THE RACE.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
NOW LISTEN, NOW, NOW SINCE
ONE OF THOSE CANDIDATES IS A
WOMAN, I CAN NOW REFER TO
THE REST OF THE REPUBLICAN
FIELD AS 12 ANGRY MEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAVE BEEN SITTING ON THAT
ONE FOR A WHILE.
APPROXIMATELY FOR 45 YEARS.
GOOD TO FINALLY GET IT OUT.
OH, OH, THIS IS SO MUCH FUN.
OKAY SO, JINDAL ANNOUNCED,
VIA NANNY CAM.
>> I THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT
THIS.
WE HAVE DECIDED WE ARE GOING
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Larry: WHAT IS THAT, TO
CATCH A PRESIDENT?
WHAT-- THAT JUST LOOKED
CREEPY, RIGHT?
WHAT'S GOING ON OVER THERE.
I MEAN BUT HE OBVIOUSLY DID
THIS SO HE COULD CATCH HIS
KID'S SPONTANEOUS REACTION
TO THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
OKAY SO, LET'S SEE THAT
AGAIN AND PAY ATTENTION TO
THE KIDS, OKAY.
>> THAT IS HOW THEY REACTED?
THAT IS YOUR BASE.
WELL, I DONE THINK THERE'S
ANY BETTER WAY TO SHOW YOU
ARE AN INSIGNIFICANT
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT THAN
MAKING YOUR PRESIDENTIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT SEEM COMPLETELY
INSIGNIFICANT.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY-- OH, OKAY,
BY THE WAY, I HAVE TO SAY
THIS.
WE WATCHED THAT VIDEO A LOT,
OKAY.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW,
WE NOTICED SOMETHING, YOU
DON'T CATCH THIS THE FIRST
TIME YOU WATCH THE VIDEO BUT
IF YOU PLAY IT BACK A COUPLE
OF TIMES YOU CAN TELL THERE
IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
MOVING AROUND SO PLAY IT
AGAIN.
>> OKAY, LOOK, LOOK, RIGHT
THERE, RIGHT THERE, DO YOU
SEE IT?
DO YOU SEE IT?
OH MY GOSH, THAT LOOKS LIKE,
WHAT WAS THAT THING CALLED,.
>> IT'S A-- NEGRO.
>> Larry: OH MY GOSH.
>> I TOLD YOU, LARRY, I
TOLD YOU.
>> IT'S AN INCOG-NEGRO.
>> LIKE RACHEL DOLEZAL?
>> EXACTLY.
>> OKAY.
>> A WHITE WOMAN WHO DRESSES
UP LIKE BLACK WOMEN.
I DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
HUNTING THEM DOWN.
>> Larry: WOW.
BUT --
>> THERE ARE MANY THAT EXIST
IN THE WILD.
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE, LARRY.
I'VE GOT TO GO UPDATE MY
BLOG.
>> Larry: OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
OKAY.
WOW.
I HONESTLY THOUGHT THOSE
DIDN'T EXIST.
I REALLY DID.
WELL, I THINK THE LESSON
HERE IS CLEAR YOU GUYS.
EVEN IF YOU ARE MAKING A
VIDEO TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT,
ALWAYS BE ON THE LOOKOUT FOR
INCOGNEGROS.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.